[music]
>> Now, inshallah, we'll be commencing with
the first session of the day.
The techniques of Dawah related public
speaking and I believe all of you have
got these notes.
This again will be a point form talk.
So, you can keep your notes open.
The salient features have been mentioned
here.
And
in the last training program
I had given approximately
two sessions of 1 and 1/2 hour to 1 hour
45 minutes.
That's approximately 3 3 and 1/2 hours.
But this time I've given approximately 6
hours.
I don't know how long will it take.
There's only six pages.
It's about seven pages actually.
The first page is the diagram.
And the last page has only few lines, so
it's approximately actually six pages.
And if I have to read these six pages
maximum would take
10 to 15 minutes.
Now, when I give a talk, I know
approximately one page is 2 minutes of
mine.
So, if you count it as seven pages also,
it will be less than 15 minutes.
But I have kept
approximately 6 hours.
So, 15 minutes if I just read it 6 hours
if I give the explanation.
So, the explanation along with the
question answer session
would be about 12 times more. That's
what I have estimated.
But usually
the estimation doesn't turn out to be
right.
It's for two reasons.
One, it depends upon
how much I want to emphasize on one
particular point.
And it's not a prepared speech.
So, if I want to speak about my
experience or give some points, on one
point I can speak for about half an hour
or 1 hour.
I usually have to restrain myself
how much less to speak rather than how
much more to speak.
And secondly, because of the question
answer session, I'm not aware
how many questions will I get. And
normally I prefer
answering all the questions at least
related to the topic.
So,
at least the students
they are satisfied and they don't carry
this
question mark
in the mind to the next session.
Always prefer but due to time
limitation, we have to stick to the
break. We have to
try and stick as much as possible to the
time.
During the second day, alhamdulillah, we
had
more freedom because next day was a
so-called holiday.
And this freedom will be given to me at
least twice a week.
On
Thursday
and on Sunday.
So, we prepared
that Thursdays and Sundays
we have more time, so we can catch up
what we have
missed, inshallah.
This
day today
is one of the most important days
of the complete
international Dawah training program.
Let's become effective Dawah.
And that's the reason
when some of the participants were
selected
and were having problem with visa is
because we saw to it that we get the
exact visa. We have to follow the rule
of the country.
Normally, if a tourist comes and he
attends the training program, it's not a
problem, but technically it is wrong.
Every country has its own law and in
India on a tourist visa, by law
you cannot attend a training program.
You're only meant to
do sightseeing and tour. Finally, you
can meet your friends and relatives. So,
though
no one takes objection, but we want to
follow
the law of the country. So, we told all
the participants, you have to get a
special visa
for the training program.
And most of the participants, almost all
all of them, 100%, had it mentioned on
their passport for attending training
program. Many of them, 45 days IRF
public speaking training program. So,
it's specified.
So, because of that normally the visa
takes a bit more longer.
And
we had told all the participants that
apply more than a month in advance.
Some people
we give 1 and 1/2 months time.
And there were a couple of brothers who
he selected from the UK.
And we told them 1 and 1/2 months in
advance, but he was overconfident. Oh,
we can get the visa in 2 days. I said,
"See, it takes
at least two to three weeks.
May take four weeks."
He said, "No, I have to go somewhere
out.
I have to go for Umrah." Could have
applied, got the visa. He could have
adjusted his time. And the sad part of
it is yet he has not got his visa.
There were other brothers like brother
Ibrahim, masha Allah.
We had selected six people from UK. And
the reason brother Ibrahim got the visa
is why?
Can anyone guess why did brother Ibrahim
get the visa and the others didn't get?
Can you give the microphone, please?
Brother Ash, Ash want to answer.
Because he was the coordinator.
Can anyone else reply?
Yes, brother Firdous.
Fadli, sorry.
As-salamu alaykum, brother again. Wa
alaykum as-salam warahmatu Allah wa
barakatuh. Yes, brother.
Could it be he applied way more earlier
than any all the other brothers from UK?
He applied early? No, he didn't apply
early. He applied on time. We just
gave the letter of invitation hardly 1
month in advance and we never told
everyone to apply early. Some brother we
gave six weeks in advance.
Why did he get and the others didn't
get?
Yes, brother somebody.
Because Allah helped him.
Why did Allah help him and not the
others?
Is Allah unjust? Is helping one not the
other? Why?
He strive more than the others. Correct.
Allah's help is required, must. Without
that, not possible. But the rule for
getting Allah's help is it says in Surah
Ankabut, chapter 29, verse 69, if you
strive in the way of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala, Allah will open up the pathways.
So, brother Ibrahim strived and he
strove. He said, he went there
personally.
And he kept on following up
whatever he could.
He used the influence. So, he told this
person. He strived. And Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
liked the striving and Allah fulfills
his promise. So, the others did not get
because they were relaxed. They weren't
that much dedicated. Anyone who really
wants to do the course
and he strives, Allah will open up the
pathways.
So, though we had selected approximately
25 26 of the participants knowing very
well that some of them may drop at the
last moment. Some of them will not do
the job properly. So, this time we took
little bit more actually.
And we thought that we will get about
20 would come here.
That's what we estimated.
And alhamdulillah, the estimation was
right.
And this is the first time
in the history
of whenever I've taken the Dawah
training program the number always
reduces, but alhamdulillah, after first
day the number increased from 19 to 20
and on the second day 20 to 21. So,
alhamdulillah, this time we have a
dedicated batch.
that you complete the course
and inshallah, you'll become an
effective Dawah.
Yes or no?
Inshallah.
When the people asked me, "When is the
last we can come here?" So, I told them,
"The last you can come here is on the
18th morning."
So, that on the 18th you can view the
video cassette of the 16th and 17th. The
first 2 days of the training program, so
that you're in line with others. And
alhamdulillah, brother Ibrahim also had
some problem with visa and he was able
to
get it on time on the 17th. And he
reached here, alhamdulillah, yesterday
morning. And and he reached here,
alhamdulillah, yesterday morning. And
he's with us, alhamdulillah. Now, we
have total 21 candidates from 11
different countries.
Six from Malaysia,
four from India,
two from Singapore, one from Indonesia,
one from Sri Lanka, one from Japan, two
from UK,
one from Netherlands, and one from
China. So, total we have, alhamdulillah,
from 11 different countries.
Alhamdulillah.
under participants. And may Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala make it possible
with your striving
and your hard work
that all of you become effective da'is,
inshallah.
We'll be starting with page number one.
Page number one.
We start with the introduction.
And it talks about the effect
and impact of a talk.
Today's research
on public speaking,
this research tells us
that the matter a person speaks,
normally,
most of the people think that the most
important thing
in public speaking is the matter.
Yes, it is important.
But very few or hardly a negligible
percentage know that
in impact and effectiveness of a public
speech, the matter carries only 7%
weightage. Only 7%.
I'm aware most of you may have
heard my speeches before, so it may not
be new for you now.
But when the first time you heard it,
surely
it may have been shocking.
As it was shocking to me
when the first time I came to know. I
knew there were other things important,
but I did not know that the matter
carries only 7% weightage, only.
The balance 93%
is presentation skills.
>> [music]
[music]